Donald Trump is continuing his brutal
assault against plumbing and water
consumption and appliances the latest is
during a rant last night in Milwaukee
this is weird Donald Trump ranting about
dishwashers that he clearly does not
understand I'm gonna play the clip and
there's a few funny things here first
Trump is again framing everything as
liberals don't want you to have working
appliances we're working to get you good
appliances the second funny thing is
Trump clearly has no idea how
dishwashers work I'd be shocked if he
ever operated one in his life and number
three is his crowds are so clueless and
so willing to be led around by Trump
like they're on a leash that you've even
got like teenagers in the audience
cheering about dishwashers can you
imagine being 14 and going crazy because
Trump will allow you to buy certain
dishwashers that he claims liberals
don't want you to have take a look at
this bizarre clip but I'm also approving
new dishwashers that give you more water
so you can actually wash and rinse your
dishes without having to do it ten times
nine ten
I would bet money Trump has no clue how
a dishwasher works but the whole
underlying idea again is liberals want
to restrict how much water you can use
and Trump wants to let you use all the
water you want or something like that
Trump's obsession with plumbing is
getting really weird remember Donald
Trump's rant about flushing toilets ten
to fifteen times we have a situation
where we're looking very strongly at
sinks and showers and other elements of
bathrooms where you turn the faucet on
in areas where there's tremendous
amounts of water where the water rushes
out to see because you could never
handle it and you don't get any water
you turn on the faucet you don't get any
water they take a shower and water comes
dripping out stripping out very quietly
tripping out people are flushing toilets
10 times 15 times as opposed to once
they end up using more water so EPA is
looking at that very strongly and my
suggestion you go into a new building or
a new house or new home and they have
standards only you don't get water you
can't you can't wash your hands
practically this so little water comes
out of the faucet Donald Trump the
president most obsessed with plumbing
probably in the history of the United
States during the plumbing era during
the era where internal plumbing exists
in households it's all so bizarre and
disjointed and it is comical to a degree
except that he's impeached he's wreaking
havoc internationally he's the
laughingstock of the world as we played
clips for you earlier today he's
effectively employing destructive trade
policy while extorting foreign countries
to help him smear his possible opponent
in order to bolster his reelection
chances if it was only that the guy's
whacked out about plumbing and water
that'd be one thing but the water
wackiness is happening in addition to
all of these other serious Fiasco's
scandals and embarrassments and it just
has to end I mean we're getting to the
end are we going to have just another
year of this almost to the day a year
and a week of this before we inaugurate
someone else Oh
are we giving this guy an additional
four years I'm scared that it's the
latter I'm hopeful that it's the former
but we've got to work together to make
it happen